as usual we're going to go e4 and then
bishop a6
and you guys whoops mouse slip oh my god
what am i doing oh no
it's horrible uh yeah yeah oh my god i
meant to play i meant to play an
accelerated ray lopez with bishop b5 you
see this guy's like what
[Music]
oh my god i'm so stupid terrible man i
got a replacement i gotta break my mouse
i mean this is unacceptable this keeps
happening
again and again and again
okay knight takes a6 this guy
takes correctly he doesn't take b takes
a6 like the last
uh guy that we did this with now
we uh rome wasn't built in a day rome
wasn't built in a day
and so the first step when something
like this happens we're playing down a
piece we will have to unbalance the
position we will have to get attacking
chances
but before any of that we have to
develop our pieces it you know
don't make the situation worse by doing
something crazy
so we will begin with knight to f3 just
developing our knight
yeah obviously and the funny thing is
because we sacked a bishop he can't go
knight c6 so maybe that'll fluster him
somehow
uh and make it a bit harder for him to
orient himself in this position
d6 is good here at philadelphia peace is
pretty a little bit better than a
philidor
uh which is not down up a piece
and he says any mistake
question mark i i can't talk on this
account so
i'm just gonna let him speculate
all right d6 there we go philidor
now obviously
to get attacking chances we will have to
open the position up at some point and
just because we don't have a light
squared bishop doesn't necessarily mean
that we shouldn't open up the center um
so what what move am i implying may have
some meaning here
because the funny thing is d6 is a
little bit passive his bishop
is restricted by the pawn his knight on
a6 is on the rim
so if we did have a bishop we would play
d4 as a no brainer
but even without the bishop d4 makes
some sense and we need to start planning
how are we going to unbalance the
position what are we going to do
to create some sort of intrigue that
will perhaps confuse him and give us
chances
the easiest way the easiest formula to
unbalancing the position is to castle
the opposite side of
what your opponent is castling of where
your opponent is casting so if he's
castling king side which is 99
uh going to be true then we should
orient ourselves toward castling
queenside
the other thing to remember is that you
shouldn't automatically take free pawns
when they're offered to you if you're
down a piece because obviously if you
play d take c5 d take c5
and then you trade queens and you play
knight takes c5 and you celebrate that
you've won a pawn well first of all you
blunder maiden one due to rook d1 but
even if there was no mate
trading queens would be way too steep of
a price to pay for a single pawn
when you're down a piece so bishop g4 is
a phenomenal move by by our opponent
so we need to deal with this in a
different way
in a certain sense we need to keep this
pawn on d4 we need to defend it
now the best way to defend the pawn is
typically with another pawn
so what kinds of moves come to mind here
okay so queen d3 would escape the pin
but it wouldn't necessarily defend the
pawn i like the move c3
and i like that you guys know this move
from
all the rye lopez's that we've had and
we've played this move all the time it's
a good move
building up a little pawn train keeping
our pawns in the center
of course bishop b7 that's good all
right now we need to think about how to
continue our development
um you know
there isn't anything truly uh
appealing that we can do at this very
moment we have to finish our development
before
we have to play very patiently in a
sense if we go crazy and
we go queen a4 check that doesn't do
anything we don't have anything
developed
so knight d2 is the drawback of blocking
in the bishop
so can we can we circumvent that problem
by
changing the order of our development
yes we can start with bishop e3
of course bishop g5 blunders the bishop
due to bishop takes g5
so we start with bishop e3 then knight b
to d to if you're down a piece
um then you know every single piece
that's not developed hurts you
quite a bit more than when there's equal
material no of course we're lost like
everything is bad here
but we're trying to make the most of the
situation knight b to d2
yeah thank you tension have a good have
a good one
you castles okay
and now of course as i explained the
ideal
plan would be to move the queen and
castle queenside
the risks of that are very obvious we've
already played c3 that's a weakening
move so if we were to castle queenside
our king's safety would be
greatly at risk but we're not in a
position to
to like choose and we're not in a
position to experience any kind of
luxury in our king safety so queen c2 is
interesting
i still probably prefer queen e2
yeah we could also play queen b3 but the
problem with queen b3
is that he might take our knight i feel
like that queen would get vulnerable
once we castle queens and we need our
queen to somehow be able to participate
in a future kingside attack that's what
i'm trying to say
if we put our queen too far away on the
queen side
then if we were to develop some sort of
a pawn storm on the king's side
the queen wouldn't be close enough to
participate in the attack
so i don't think escaping the pin is the
top priority here
i don't think escaping the pin is the
temperature but
we should have the capacity to end the
pin when we want to
so we should start with the move h3 now
of course he can take the knight and he
can trade
that's not necessarily good for us but
at least it eliminates a headache of a
bishop
and lets us activate our queen and
prepare to castle so we do
accomplish some of the things that we
wanted to
uh in particular eliminating the bishop
and now we have
you know pretty clear plan of going g4
g5 and beginning the pawn star
right yeah we could have considered g
takes f3 and open the g file but the g
file alone would not have done us too
many
favors and i'll show you guys why after
the game that's a good question
yeah that's it's a bit hard to explain
i'll have to show it
he says do you want drop no
no that was earlier
i mean he thinks it's a mouse if he's
trying to be nice
okay c5 now we need to be very careful
here
as to how we approach this because
if i'm reading the chat correctly i
think a lot of you
would have the tendency to go d5 here
and d5 is bad d5 is very bad
because d5 closes down the center and
it unties his hands completely for an
attack on the
queen side he can go b5 and then c4 and
b4 and he's so much faster than us his
queen comes out to a5 right
so in a certain sense by keeping the
center open
you're diluting the his ability
to attack our queen side and in a
completely
unfettered way in addition in addition
he's weakened a lot of squares by
playing c5 i know it sounds completely
irrelevant but he's weak in this square
he's sort of blunted his own bishop the
knight on a6 can't go to c5 anymore
so by keeping the center open we are
emphasizing the superiority of our
pieces
and i'll tell you guys more we can
actually play positionally even though
we're down a piece that's not doesn't
mean that we can't make any positional
moves so what comes to mind here
yeah so first of all we can castle um
but i like to move knight c4 the pro
there's only one problem with knight c4
knight c4 he can slide his queen into d3
and that's an incredibly nasty move
queen to d3
so i would risk it and castle
i would risk it and castle first because
this
gives us the possibility of attacking
the king side that plan is still in
is still very much available that plan
is still very much available
queen a5 of course we have to defend the
pawn
a lot of you would go a3 here
automatically but you don't want to make
any more weaknesses on the queen side we
already have gone c3
so of course nb1 is the automatic
response now if he attacks
in a very focused way he's going to win
but we are banking on the fact that he
hesitates
or that he gets scared of our attack and
you know that's where we just got to
pray
it's out of our hands we're doing what
we can i we've made some progress toward
complicating the game he's playing very
well
he's playing very well but it's not as
easy as it was when we gave the piece up
okay so let's try to understand what our
plan is what is our plan
can somebody lay out the general how are
we going to attack his king side what
what is the series of steps here
now i've indicated this move g4 many
times what is the function of g4 what is
the purpose of the pawn storm
what does the pawn storm do it does two
things the first is that it removes the
knight from f6 that's the main defender
that's the gatekeeper the initial
gatekeeper
once the gatekeeper is gone we push the
other pawn to h5 and we try to go g6
there are there's one fundamental
purpose of a pawn storm
and that is to break open the cover of
his king
there is another related purpose of a
pun storm and that is to use the pawns
to secure
squares for your pieces that's a lesser
known application of the pawn storm
i'll talk about that after the game but
the you know most of the pawn storms
that you see in the sicilian and all
those
traditional attacks you try to advance
your pawns and sacrifice them
to open files for your rooks and queen i
was going to say rooks and queens but
if you have more than one queen you
don't really need a pawn star
and again i'll tackle all of your
individual questions afterwards
yeah well do you say i'm worried about
it but this is a move that's good for us
because his rook should have been on b8
and there comes b5 well we've entered a
point of no return
we've entered a point of no return we
have to we have to continue our attack
and just pray
that somehow we end up being faster than
he is
if only we had a light squared bishop
we gotta send it no choice h4 only way i
mean
there's just no other way to attack
literally
you don't need to be a gm to make these
moves
all in i'm okay okay this is good you
see he panics he panics
he's trying to slow down the progress of
her pawns
but in doing so he creates a pawn hook
he makes it a lot worse for himself
why why is this move so bad can somebody
explain that to me of course we go h5
and this pawn by acting as a hook allows
us to open the h file a lot faster and
all we need is one open file
as long as we can open a file we're
going to be good we're going to have
enough
avenues and streets to create serious
threats against this king this might not
be winning yet
but the position has been greatly
complicated
that's why the rule exists to warn you
against pushing pawns on the side where
you're being attacked
now what i want you guys to understand
is that htx g6 will be hasty
we don't want to play h6 g6 too quickly
what move do we want to play first
to prepare h6 the threat is stronger
than this execution
we have only one shot to open the h file
we want to go queen to h3
we want to double up first and then take
on g6
that may seem absurd why who can explain
to me why we want to play queen h3 here
and that is a crushing move
what's wrong with taking and then going
queen h3
because of course yeah he has f takes g6
and he's going to use that f7 square for
his rook
to defend the pawn so by keeping things
closed until we need to open them we
disallow defensive moves like rook f7 i
think he has no defense i think he's
busted
this is going to come and then this
h-file massacre is going to happen
whether he likes it or not
and this move g6 lost him the game
there's nothing he can do because if he
takes then we take and
it's the same thing he did trap his own
queen but that's much less important
yeah this is nice this was a very nice
game
17 moves only it seemed like a lot
longer didn't it
it seemed like 50 like we were trying
this and that but it was only 17 moves
all right i'll give him a draw because
he i agree with that
notion now the ratings are refunded
anyway
but i will give him a draw as a symbolic
gesture
it is made though this is literally made
in two and the may will come on the next
move
because if if if i made one more move he
might have resigned so i'll give him the
draw
no i on on your i think your guy's a
suggestion was a good one
i agree
and it's it's good you know bishop a6
that was very sweet of him to just sort
of assume it was a male slip
and say offer a draw that's nice
so i'll
well the point is we we made the
comeback here
yeah wholesome stuff by our opponent he
might just resign i don't know maybe
he'll he'll not understand
i think what's going through his head
right now i think what's what's going
through his head right now
is that he thinks he thought he was
mated now he's suspicious that i offered
a draw
so he's looking for some crazy crazy
resource
um that that he thinks i may have missed
that often happens
yes of course godnag i'll show you
everything
can you revoke the drone no so there's a
couple of stories that i have
um in scholastic tournaments this is a
very common thing that kids do when
they're not very well behaved
uh i've been witness to this where a kid
will offer a draw
tauntingly in a winning position the
other kid will accept
and then the first kid will say i never
offered a draw
and you know the other kid will call
over the td but there's no proof
assuming that there's nobody sitting
next to them there's no proof that you
offered to draw anybody could say well
my opponent offered me a draw here
so that's something i've i've heard
stories about several times this has
never happened to me
although i've played kids who've offered
me draws like 15 times in a row
in a completely lost position that's
pretty common
and then of course i had my most epic
story ever about the kid who tried to
cheese me into blonde ring mate and
ended up losing a piece and then he
started crying and then of course i felt
bad
that was the same kid who oh he declines
it
he declined it oh man
well okay that's fair that's fair
okay fine so what do we need to do here
do we need to take do we need to take
the knight do we need to react to this
move
really brandon wait who who
do we need no no no god forbid do not
take this and i do not pass go
ignore everything make sure that he's
not threatening checkmate
if he had gone like b4 then yes we would
have had to take his knight
when you are on the cusp of me one piece
of advice
pay attention to what your opponent is
doing because he might make these
spike moves to threaten something and if
you just
tunnel vision your idea you might at the
last second miss some crazy idea
it was over it's over you won't say it
fair enough
yeah so knight takes you two we can we
can take with either piece rook takes
you to has
more of an elegance to it queen takes h5
obviously
and mate is on the board
nice game
offer a draw over the board you usually
say i offer a draw
sorry he didn't please you usually say
you you play a move and you say offer a
draw or you
you can you can just say draw uh if
you're playing international chess or
playing world youth you you make this
symbol
because if if it's assumed that your
player that you know that there's no
common language
absolutely it was okay there's a lot to
unpack in this game
amazing with bishop a6 thank you for the
300 isp
unexplained
all right yeah sure her
so d64 opening up the center
and i like his move bishop g4 hatigani
takes d4
harigani takes d4 which
piece would we have taken with this is
an interesting question
to test your guys's understanding of
what our ultimate plan
is think about how we want to get our
pieces out very nice
queen queen because first of all he's
got no knight c6
and second of all because we want to
castle along asap
and to do that we need to clear our
queen off the board then we want to go
knight c3 bishop g5
and quit castle and perhaps we can even
go e5 quickly if he doesn't develop
officially
so that's um what we would have done
c3 right defending the pawn now why do
we want to cast along
because thank you scat man for the tier
one
because as i explained the easiest way
to unbalance a position
is to generate attacking chances and to
generate attacking chances
you generally need to castle to the side
that is opposite of the side that you're
attacking assuming that you're using
your pawns if you're using your pawns to
attack
you're castled on that same side it's
going to be a lot harder to do that
without weakening your king that should
be intuitively obvious
so castling to the opposite side
basically says i won't need to worry as
much about my king safety i could throw
my pawns on my opponent
and i don't need to factor in that
additional variable does that mean that
it is impossible
to attack on the same side where you're
castled absolutely not
it's possible even to attack with a pawn
storm but that requires quite often a
lot more skill
and uh you know there's a lot more risk
attendant to that
okay so c3 uh defending
the pawn well
it also stops night before which is a
nice byproduct of it but the main reason
i played c3 is just to
buttress the pawn because if we make a
random move
he can simply take the knight and we
either have to ruin our structure
or give up another pawn and that's just
too much
so c3 is is sort of a necessity okay so
bishop e3 completing the development
knight bd2 that's the only way for us to
complete the development
now after h3 i think this was the
beginning of his troubles
i would play bishop h5 if i were black
because if we go g4
our position collapses the pawn on e4 is
a tremendously weak pawn
the center is going to open and it's
going to open up before we get a chance
to castle along
so for example if you go queen c2 here
black and strike with d5 exploiting the
pin this is just totally crushing
so something like that would have been
very difficult
to defend against yeah so keeping the
king in the center can often be a good
strategy
if you think the center can be the
safest place to keep the king that
sometimes happens
um okay yeah but should be six is fine
but yeah but then black has to give up
the pawn but then black has to give up
the pawn which
is a reasonable thing to do but perhaps
he didn't want to do that
all right so a lot of you are asking why
not gf to open up the g-file and
what what you should understand is that
how do you how should you think of an
attack you should think of an attack
as sort of a cumulative set of factors
that together give you
chances to mate your opponent's game and
when you look at this position you say
ah
i've got the g file you're already
imagining something happening on g7
but one open file alone
is not enough it's not enough substance
to generate serious threats in most
cases
why is that what's an example of a
defensive setup
that black can adopt to prevent damage
along the g file
black can play the move g6 here now i
know it was bad in the game
but i'm associating this with a very
specific follow-up
okay so let's say rook g1
now i'm gonna put my knight on h5 why am
i doing this i'm doing this to blockade
the pawn
to prevent the move f4 just freeze both
of the pawns
and if i need to i'll move my king away
to h8 i could even fianchetto my bishop
just just to cover all the bases
entirely
so as you guys can see even though we're
occupying the g
file there isn't enough real estate
available on the king side
the market is too hot we can't push our
pawns you can't create more weaknesses
and black has too many defenders
so g takes f3 makes too many positional
sacrifices
for a benefit that isn't substantive
enough to give serious attacking chances
does that make sense
i don't know if that makes sense so when
you're considering whether to do
something like this
take with a pawn to open a file you have
to put things in the broader context is
the open file the only thing i'm getting
am i getting other benefits will i be
able to provoke more weaknesses
and particularly if you're down a piece
you need to keep your options as open as
possible
all right yeah you need the g pawn as a
as an instrument of the pawn storm thank
you okay so c5
i believe is a mistake good night
brandon
great games give him a follow by the way
he ain't too shabby himself all right
um now c5 is a very awkward move
and the reason i know it's an awkward
move is because i've made this mistake
myself
a lot of the times that i immediately
identify whether move is good or bad is
because i simply have the experience of
either playing it or facing it
and getting chastised for it and
i played c5 i remember playing c5 in a
completely different position but it was
it was a mistake for a very similar
reason and uh this was one of my first
games against against the grandmaster
i think my very first game against a
grandmaster i made a very similar
mistake
so this is my game against mela kachion
who is a great who's an armenian
grandmaster now lives in la
uh but now he i mean he's a he's a good
friend i've known him for many years
and uh this was my first ever game
against the gm yeah in 2007 i was 2100
so i was i was you know i was pretty
good um
so we have a position where it's sort of
like a
perk or a kings indian type of structure
chaos nad thinking for the prime and
guess what move i played in this
position is black guess what move i play
it here
i played c5 yeah so my reasoning
was that i'm trying to contest this i'm
trying to control more of the center you
know i'm trying to push upon instead
but i simply ignored the fact that the
first thing is that i'm creating a
giant hole on d5 this is a square which
can never be defended by the c
pawn again and what malek does
is eventually he puts a knight on d5
right eventually he
creates a plan where he's going to move
his knight out
then he's going to use his dark squared
bishop and trade it for the only
defender of the square
and then ideally he's going to bring the
knight around to d5 which is exactly
what he does
takes h4 okay he provokes other
weaknesses so it's not that simple
but basically he runs circles over me
using all of these weaknesses that i've
created
and it all it all centers around the d5
square so i got crushed
positionally crushed um
and it's very similar if we transfer
that to the uh to the speedrun game
again it creates a huge hole in d5 and
it really makes all the pieces just
dull all right so maybe i'm belaboring
the point here
but c5 in such situations you got to be
very careful about
what i would do instead is probably go
c6
same idea you want to open up the queen
in preparation for castles long
but this is better in the sense of
preparing b5 before etc etc
so c5 and so on and so on d takes e5 d
takes e5
castle is long this is a must because
otherwise our king is just going to be
stranded in the center and we can't
allow that
um so yeah why not d5
this is a bit hard for me to explain but
the bottom line is
is nimzovich aaron nem zavitchway is a
frequent
uh reference on this stream right he
wrote my system
he makes the analogy of sort of a
dentist who feels a cavity
you know c5 creates a cavity on d5
and nimzovich talks about it as like
when you close the center prematurely
you you basically give your opponent a
free visit to the dentist you know
longer has a cavity because it's filled
with the pawn
and these pawns on c5 and e5 are not
protected by d6 let me make it in
another color
the pawn on d6 which i've i'm going to
highlight in green
is protecting its counterparts on e5 and
c5
and the bottom line is that black can
still attack on the queen side you're
closing the center but you're not
preventing black from attacking on the
queen side
now by opening the center you are
diluting black's attention this pawn is
weak
sorry whoops do you want me to do that
there we go this pawn is weak you have
an
x-ray going who knows this is kind of in
white's favor
and maybe you can use the d5 square
later
we're not ruling out the fact that this
knight much like in that game that i
just showed you is going to make its way
to d5
so it's not that black can't use it to
his advantage thank you aeko
it's that black is unlikely to use it
for his advantage there's nothing about
the d
file that is in black's favor other than
the fact that black could use it
to trade a bunch of pieces because he's
up a piece that's a risk we're taking
now i don't know if it makes sense if
that makes if i could explain this in in
another way but
that's the bottom line logic okay queen
a5
now of course we go king b1 the
reasoning is simple we have to defend
the pawn on a2
the reason that a3 is a bad move here is
exactly the same reason that g6 is a bad
move here
this creates a hook and now we have two
hooks
and black can exploit those hooks by
just exploding upon
on b4 that's going to guarantee that the
position rips apart
you want to go king b1 well king c2
doesn't defend the pawn
king c2 doesn't defend the pawn right
maybe you want to go here but the queen
has a nice way out
via e6 also the king on c2 is a lot more
susceptible to various checks and
sacrifices
all right so our opponent started going
astray here
i would straight away go for b5 right i
would go b5
but this is the hardest moment for black
because a lot of people would
automatically go before now who can
explain to me why b4 is not a good move
before and it isn't a good move for
several reasons actually
well knight c4 isn't really a fork
because first of all i don't really care
about the spawn i can go queen b5 and
x-ray the king
and even if i wanted to care about i
could go back to c7 the reason is c4
and look at how the queen side is sort
of locked up knight and queen are
staring at the spawn
and it's hard for black to make progress
on the other hand we're gonna start
pushing our pawns
so what should black do here how should
black ensure that the attack does not
die
after black plays b4 this is a very
important
technique very important technique first
you play c4 and then you play b4 you
feel the cavity
then you play b4 even if it means
sacking the spawn
so after g5 i would move the knight
let's say knight
yeah 98 maybe even 98 because knight d7
would stand in the x-ray of the rook yes
this disconnects the rooks but you can
get the knight around to d6
so h4 knight d6 h5 and here comes b4
and this is a beautifully placed knight
that's defending the pawn
and black is crushing here white just
isn't in time you can go g6
bc black you know we can take h7 the
king can use the pawn as an umbrella
you can see that white is a little bit
close if we had three four more moves we
would have gotten somewhere but black is
literally all over white's throat
so that would be the best way for black
to guarantee that his attack would be
faster
our opponent plays rook a2d8 which is a
good move in general but a waste of time
given the specific properties of the
position which is that he needs to
attack asap
so a hook is sort of a
something you lash on to so think about
why a pawn storm is conducted
you conduct a pawn storm to open up the
king side right
these are hooks they're still hooks just
because they haven't moved doesn't mean
they act as
hooks a hook is an opponent's pawn that
you are trying to
make contact with to open up files but
when a pawn is advanced
literally just mathematically it is
you know your pawn advance that makes
contact with it is going to come
much faster and it might even be more
the more pawns act
as hooks the more explosive it is the
more files may open
all right all right now again
i don't want anybody to take this as
gospel there are plenty of situations
plenty of situations where you do want
to push puns
and create hooks there's a very compel
sometimes there's a very compelling
reason to do so
sometimes what may seem like a hook is
actually
a way to slow down the attack there's a
lot of these variables
you have to factor in and i can give you
plenty of examples
i can give you plenty of examples of
moves that may seem completely
unplayable because they help the
opponent but in reality
slow down an attack that otherwise would
have been quite devastating
right there's just a lot of complexity
when it comes to attacking
it's like h4 meeting h4 with h5
and i can give you a very simple example
just to contextualize this although this
is far from
what i really mean by this this is just
a skeletal kind of example
this is the king's indian samish
variation
and you can see that white's going to
castle long and we're going to have
opposite side castling my opponent goes
g4
and his plan is to checkmate me in the
very typical way he's going to go h4h5
and
she's going to open the h ball maybe so
what do you think black can do here it's
a very odd looking move if you've never
seen this idea before
but it has the effect of keeping the h
files
blockaded h5 you meet g4 with h5
and you might say well wait a minute
doesn't the age file open up well kind
of but he
still has a pawn on h2 which is the
important part and this knight acts as a
blockader
not permanent but it buys you time to
attack on the queen side most of the
defensive techniques that you
execute are in the end ways to buy
yourself time so you can attack more
rapidly on the other side
it's not about stopping your opponent's
attack permanently although that would
be nice
it's about buying yourself time and if
he goes h3 then we just
just keep the pawn on h5 you use it as a
deterrent you could even shove it to h4
and even though white would eventually
win that pawn it would take him a while
to do that and then move the bishop back
away
and then go edward try it's like
knockout and basketball right you
you use your basketball to hit your
opponent's basketball and by the time
that they run and get it and make a
basket
you've already made 18 layups it's it's
the same kind of principle
right you sacrifice a pawn by the time
he get takes that pawn and moves the
bishop away and puts the h bond that's
like
5 6 10 b all right
okay well if g5 then you can go knight
e8 or you can go down h7 you know
i would go 98 and maybe reroute the
knight like this eventually
yeah okay so not to get too sidetracked
um and those of you who find this
concept intuitive you know sorry to
to be labor it's a g4 b5 g5 97 hr but
really the decisive mistake comes here
g6 is a very very very bad move
and once again i think had he gotten c4
and then had he gone either before
immediately
and knight takes c4 is not scary why is
this not scary where should the queen go
where should black screen go and i
already mentioned this move in a
different context
yes that could be a very effective
method of course queen b5 creating the
x-ray attack in the knight and b takes
c3 is going to be crushing
but if for whatever reason you were
worried about this you could go knight
to b6
and then b4 and still i think black's
attack is much faster
so g6 is the decisive mistake h no h6
just allows g takes h6
g6 h5 and i i think the black and
black has a very advanced defensive
technique here oh but there's a
beautiful line though
so the advanced defensive technique is
to say i need to defend the h7 pawn at
all costs
who can well knight f6 we just take it
paula who can
who can identify a method of defending
this pawn in time
this is a very common method in the
sicilian and various openings
where you encounter a natural attack
it's rookie 8 and knight fa
and black is in time to hold this
together but after rookie ate there
you have to notice that the f7 pawn has
been weakened
well who gives a damn about that right
who gives a damn if the f7 pawn is weak
it's not like you can put a rook on f1
and x-ray through the f2 pawn
well you kind of can h takes g6 and now
another relatively common tactical
pattern rook takes h7
overloading king has to take the rook
otherwise it's made
check checkmate
again a pattern that if you've done a
lot of puzzles
you've seen before i'm quite sure
yeah um it's a very i really like this
one though
why not f6 and rook f7
well f6 you're not in time h takes g6
i'm not going to let you put a rook
there and now i'm going to go queen h3
maybe the king can run but that looks
absolutely
miserable so this is going to be a
very one-sided king hunt how would you
break the umbrella if you didn't go g6
well
like i said if you didn't go g6 and
didn't do anything
i would have gone h5 and then probably
g6 myself
and try to explode stuff yeah sure so um
and i'm always happy to repeat stuff so
g6 h5 i was saying rick fe-8
this weakens the f7 pawn so we start by
taking on g6
now you might say but didn't you say
that you should delay this move until
you're ready to take it well
that was in the event that he doesn't do
this here
sorry my voice cracks here the
circumstances have changed you need to
exploit the f7 square while you still
can
and you do that by sacking the rook on
h7
you're threatening checkmate so he has
to take the rook now you don't want to
give this check this check would be very
hasty
because the king just moves aside and
then if we go here and say ah it's me
well he obviously just defends so
instead you want to start by giving this
check
cornering the king and then mating at an
h1 does that make sense
now if he doesn't take my pawn back on
g6
well what does he do i mean you're
threatening queen takes f7 or rook takes
h7
it's not like he's on the doorstep of
mating me he's
five or six moves away himself but we
don't have to worry about any of that
right okay
what if sac bishop g7 i'm not sure what
you wear
what if he plays h6 yeah well that's a
problem
well that's that's a problem and
normally we have more pieces in the
attack
you could sack on h6 i mean
let me show you guys a quick example of
how how this kind of stuff works
what i wanted to show you i can just
make moves here um
myself so normally in the sicilian
let me just let me just very quickly
approximate what could happen
so this is like a common line of the
sicilian
now what often happens is you get a
situation like this and let's make
random moves for black
so this is similar but different because
if you go g6 and black goes h6
you often have this battery already
pre-built so you can just snap the pawn
on h6
and this is checkmate because knight f6
for example to defend the square you can
go g7 you can take
everything is crushing so oftentimes
you have this response oftentimes you
can take on f7
and use the g file the problem is and
this is where you just have to put
things in context because we're down a
piece here
um g6 is just not that dangerous so i
agree
i agree that
in in this position it would be a lot
harder to
get stuff done but maybe one thing we
could do is go rook g1
or perhaps you could consider a bishop
sack
and then rook two i mean this looks
interesting right this doesn't look easy
to defend against we're threatening
this and this there's all sorts of very
cool stuff that can arise from this
i don't know if i'm making sense you
could just keep throwing pieces at your
opponent
and hope that something good comes of it
sometimes that's what attacking is all
about
right so
there's no clear science to this
remember that your ultimate goal when
you're pawn storming is to
either open up your opponent's king
that's the main reason another thing
that you can do with the pawn storm is
use the pawns to weaken squares
that can be the case in the event of a
lobster pencer so if we reposition
black's pieces
and we have this position and it's white
to move
who can propose an even more effective
way
what would we do here would we still go
g6 or would there be a better idea
and i've given you of course a very big
hint
why is all of this significant now his
pieces are all away from the king side
h6 is very common
yeah and this is lobster pincer but if
we
if we did something as small as
reposition a rook on e8
h6 would already be bad because this is
a
very narrow you're putting all of your
eggs in one basket and if it doesn't
work
uh you know there's a good russian
expression you're at a broken gate
all of a sudden you end up without what
you thought you would have if that makes
sense
your sol yeah
okay um yeah we have all been there
so you've got to be very careful when
you're when you're making a very
specific move like h6 you got to be
careful that it is in fact lobster
fencer bait
g6 is safer because you guarantee that
yogan files
all right but that's why
one of the most common mistakes that
players make when they learn about pawn
storms
is they forget that the ultimate goal is
to open files so they forget that they
can
sacrifice pawns in order to open files
you don't need to prepare
pawn storming moves for example
sometimes
if you're trying to open the g file and
you want to go g4
but the g4 square is defended you can
still go g4 because if the opponent
takes on g4
you've succeeded in opening the g file
you're fine sacrificing pawns
and i have a very simple example of that
before we move on to the next game
so we have a dark squared bishop and
this bishop is uncontested it is very
clear
that we want to attack white's king so
as i put a little bit more sugar in my
tea
who can propose the best and most
efficient method
of starting the attack against white's
king applying the concept that i just
outlined
then we'll move on and a lot of you guys
will spot this immediately but
um
i see a lot of you indicating the
correct idea
now i've given this position by now to
all of my students
um ranging from like a thousand to
twenty four hundred
and i would say that the threshold where
people start finding the move very
quickly the correct move is about
17 1800. at a 17 1800 level
and above people say b5 almost
immediately that is the correct move
that is the correct move um
and the reason that is the correct move
is because it is a multi-purpose move
you are preparing c4 and then a5 and b4
you're gonna use the pawns to destroy
him
and if knight takes b5 which is what
deters
some other players from playing this
move well then you've opened up the b
file
and black is completely winning it's not
one of those things where you're opening
it up and then you're exploiting it
you just go rugby 8 and the game is over
because as soon as the bishop moves
b2 is going to fall if white tries to
establish the bishop on b5
then you use your a pawn dislodging the
bishop and winning the game
um but some of the low-rated people
will either suggest to a6 first to
prepare b5
or bishop d7 bishop d7 by the way is not
a bad move but it's a little bit
inefficient
and i like that nobody cared about this
one this is another pawn that you are
sacrificing by the way
which nobody cares about let him take
this one it doesn't hurt you
so b5 is the most efficient way to
attack if he plays bishop takes b5
yeah i see what you want to do but for
starters i can play bishop take c3 and
win a piece for starters
um but i'm sure that i have other moves
as well now my opponent took on f5
i played c4 bishop before a5
i mean look how effortlessly the attack
goes rook hu1
queen f6 loading up the battery just
getting out of the x-ray
b4 and now knight b5 occupying the
square left behind the
pawn knight takes c4 bishop v7 i've
given up the c pawn to open up the c
file now
and now i'm getting a rook to c8 knight
to d4 and the final move of the attack
is very very nice
and this is the third purpose of pawns
pawns can be used as anchor points
four pieces i won't tell you the move i
want people to find the move
use one of black's pawns as an anchoring
point for
a piece to go onto a devastating square
the move is a4
and you want to go knight b3 and take
not just take the rook but checkmate him
on b2 for example
check and queen b2 is a very pretty
checkmate i mean look at how all the
pieces
essentially are cooperating in a totally
devastating attack over abundance if you
could do this without a bunch of these
pieces
um well knight takes b5 is mostly
intuition but the calculation is very
simple
you don't need to see a6 for example
because you should even if you reach
this point and don't see the move a6 you
should still go
for this you should sense that the b
file is so valuable
you could you could even go bishop d7
here where it comes towards
so knight can't take queen because
because of the pin
because the knight is pinned to the game
um
but the bottom line is that you don't
always need to prepare these moves you
can play them immediately
sometimes you do need to prepare them
but a lot of the time you're pawn
storming to open files to the lesson
here
that you can just kind of throw your
pawns at your opponent and it's a
win-win
if he takes those pawns then you've got
open files if he doesn't take the pawns
well then you use those very same pawns
and push them forward and expose more
weaknesses
all right um that pawn from a7 is what
wins the game
look at how that pawn it goes from a7 to
a5 to a4 and he resigned here he
resigned in this position because knight
b3 is utterly unstoppable
all right beautiful